Western Civilization is what gave the
world pretty much every goddamn liberal
precept that Liberals are supposed to
adore let's go back to Bill Maher who I
think is he's I don't know that he'll
ever vote the right way but he's having
his red pill moment let him have it here
he is and finally new rule for all the
progressives and academics who refer to
Israel as an outpost of Western
Civilization like it's a bad thing
please note Western Civilization is what
gave the world pretty much every godamn
liberal precept that Liberals are
supposed to
adore individual liberty scientific
inquiry rule of law religious freedom
women's rights human rights democracy
trial by jury freedom of speech please
somebody stop us before we Enlighten
again and since one can find all these
Concepts in today's Israel and virtual
nowhere else in the Middle East if
anything the world would be a better
place if it had more israels of course
this message falls on deaf ears to the
current crop who reduce everything to
being only victims or victimizers so
Israel is lumped in as the toxic fruit
of the victimizing West the irony being
that all marginalized people live better
today because of Western ideals not in
spite of
them
Martin Luther King used Henry David
Thor's essay Civil Disobedience to help
shape the Civil Rights Movement the un's
universal Declaration of Human Rights
owes its core to rouso and Vol kenes
never showed up for a sexual harassment
seminar but without him there's no
democracy the cop who murdered George
Floyd got 21 years for violating his
Fourth Amendment writes an idea we got
directly from John Lock who no one in
college would ever study anymore because
he's so old and so white and so
dead so Western yes that's how simple
the woke are it's never about
ideas if it was would they be cheering
on Hamas for their
Liberation Liberation to do what more
freely preside over a country where
there are no laws against sexual
harassment spousal rape domestic
violence homophobia honor killings or
child marriage this is who liberals
think you should stand with women there
should be so lucky as to get colonized
by anybody else and for the record the
Jews didn't colonize Israel or anywhere
ever except maybe boa
Ron so that's what we're up against and
Bill's in that that little sliver of
liberals let say who are still trying to
do it but if you care about any of those
things look I get it the the let's say
most radical islamist and Marxist
portion of those protesters maybe they
don't care about those things they
either want us to live in some caliphate
or they want us you know the marxists
want us to all live under their thumb or
something but if you watching this right
now if you have a cousin that's confused
about this stuff or a child who's
confused about this or a parent or
whatever that's not really like a
psychotic ideolog like lunatic you have
a little window right now to to Deb
brainwash these people you got to
deprogram these people and you better do
it quick or it will keep getting worse
everything will keep getting worse so we
have to strengthen the people who are
fighting it and and we have to make sure
that the people who are going down those
roads know what the truth
is